I want to come back to this because I
know it's confusing you got a look at it
larger factors yesterday and sir
I want to address over why is mr. Cooney
money I want to address a point that I
know is quite easy to get it wrong I
want us to understand like when you
enlarge something what results if you
have like we've numbers for your
enlargement factor okay
so you've all seen a diagram like this
in fact I heard some of you have made a
diagram just like this okay if I say
he's an original shape the big one and I
wanted a larger factor of two okay the
important thing is these guys here these
things in green and orange do you notice
these right do you remember measuring
these out this is what makes the
enlargement actually function that this
leg and this leg are in a ratio of one
to two okay so from the original shape
to your new shape when you compare each
of the features the enlargement factor
two means you're two times further away
from your center of a larger cause
that's what they form okay so if you
come back to that as the definition
right it's all about the ratios of
distances then you'll understand what it
means if you get given an enlargement
factor it's less than one okay now this
is confusing because it's called an
enlargement factor okay but if you come
back to the definition so for example
remember I said he's my red one which is
my original shape okay by the way we
call this the original and the image I
take this distance I take this distance
from each of the features one two three
four to the centre of enlargement and
for the new version the new shape I want
the ratio to be 1/2 1/2 right so that's
what makes it closer in okay by being
closer to my centre of enlargement you
aren't necessarily and that's why you
get a new shape that's half the size of
the original so don't be deceived this
idea of like enlarging well depending on
the knob you put it it doesn't make it
larger animal okay so come back to the
definition of what something is if you
get confused about it this shape is
smaller okay
so I want you to make sure you've got
that idea clear and then I'll put it up
again in a minute okay we'll have time
the heading out now like you to make is
finding sides yeah sure okay so if you
want to think about for example I'll
just play it back for a second if you
want to come back to this okay yeah yeah
sure I can answer that question three so
I guess if my subtly changed the way
right if I said you here's a shape I
would like you to enlarge it by a factor
of zero five right so that means it's
like well you must get bigger right you
must get B that's what the word says
okay but here like what we're talking
about is like it's almost as if that
were there in larger it's not actually
there it's really just a factor that
you're changing news 5
and it's about these lengths the legs
here are the important things between
corresponding points okay so for that
reason what you get in it has to be
smaller right it has to be smaller
because really it's more about the fact
that factor I'm comparing these ratios
rather there until you explicitly I want
to make this thing bigger okay um I
suppose another thing is the difference
between of and by conjunctions and nasty
things it tiny but they can change a lot
of mean right so if I make something big
up by 50% all right can I say like once
50% or something those are completely
different up there does that make sense
like it's the difference in 100 to 150
or 100 to 50 so that's how
seventy-five percent question and it was
like fine and they gave you like lengths
right like as in and tell you is this
this and then that's how you calculate
oh yeah is that the question yeah sure
that's a good question
the answer is in the context of those
questions you don't you don't and that's
that's okay
because if you think about it a ratio of
two to one and a ratio of one to two if
you've got these shapes and they're
annoying any order in particular like we
just there on the page
yeah then these are actually the same
ratio yeah it's like one is twice the
size of the other one and I don't have
any labels on either it says that's the
first one if that's the second one so if
you're not if you don't give me an order
then I can't give you something which
has water in it right whereas of course
if there's something which is like so
later on when we look into further that
halfway through they're going to talk
about scale diagram so it's like okay
there's a house plan right and then
there's the house so clearly the houses
the original thing and the plan is what
you've driven through until I reflect
that right so therefore that will answer
the question of water for you but if
they until you order then you don't have
to wear them all right so I think I was
halfway through actually giving you the
title here the title was finding sides
of silly games
yeah of course yeah it's a straight line
okay so here's what I'm gonna home to
say to you right similar figures didn't
even bother you tell you about a
definition for what similar figures are
by any chance yes yeah I can't click it
good so I want to give you a slightly
more technical definition obviously
similar figure right a similar figure is
a shape that preserves two things two
things okay
the characteristics and the proportions
of one shape to another but alters the
size so let me write that way it's a
shape that preserves the characteristics
and also the proportions
while altering size okay now you can see
this is like what you said before but it
was in more colloquial language before
thought it looks it looks the same what
we might it looks the same is if it's
got four sides before it's gonna have
four sides again right order for half
final 15 or whatever and if there was
one side it was twice as long as another
one then it's still gonna be twice as
long and then you shake okay what are
you doing is making begone
what's more okay now here's the
important thing if you therefore know
that these are going to preserve from
one shape to another then if you notice
something about the original shape you
can take everything you know all those
relationships and characteristics there
and you can apply them to your mission
so here's an example of what I mean
would you if you have a rule there throw
this for me
ah so you can hear transformations kinda
but not those are doing that conquering
fears rather than similar ones please
not just the characteristics of motion
but the size the same so I want you to
draw for me to trapeziums
and do your best to make them similar
come in hey different list
okay so you've got some um got some
measurements on there now here's the
idea
right if you know that these shapes are
similar if you know they've got all the
same characteristics and proportions
then if you know all of these things you
can find out all of these things right
now you look before it fighting this
case and logic fractal thing right so
what you need to do is compare two
lengths that correspond okay is really
important in fact I'm going to label
them as such corresponding yes you can
see what we had to do em m1 and m2 for
this right and so if you connect these
two together you can see they're in the
ratio 8 to 16 which is 1 to 2 right both
of them are fine but I might as well
state it as simply as I can okay
so therefore if going in this direction
now cleared out to Sandy's question now
I do have a direction now I'm saying
this is the first one that's the second
one I can do the same thing for all the
other signs so going from here to this
side which corresponds they're the ones
that sit on top of each other this
should be 1 to 2 as well all right so
what's that gonna be it's new say
between 2 right when I go to this
right-hand side I'm going to use the
same ratio make sure I correspond to the
same length and again I'm going to
double it right so what's gonna happen
hey good and last one in down here 23
this is gonna be I can't wonderful